[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sullivan
heute gibt's eine wunsch torte von
vielen vielen vielen vielen zuschauern
und war lese ich fast und war doch
eigentlich bei jedem video immer die den
kommentare machte eine violette fordern
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich würde es
noch nicht wer oder was violette ist
durch sein ihre weitschüsse von
modetrends wie hannah montana nur ein
bisschen anders
die sind anscheinend auf spanisch
deswegen natürlich kein wort von dem was
von mir abhängt aber sie singt sehr
schön und ja einst dann ist es diese
violette torte wenn die goldgewinner
d'italia die wird nämlich die heute
zwölf jahre alt geworden und bekommt die
torte auch von mir und sieht auch die
totale violette fan und ich glaube das
ist auch ganz gut für die karriere video
denn sie sagt immer die zähne ist meine
große pläne und keiner in der schule
glaubt ihr die arme
naja talent hast du was für dich diese
torte hier außen habe ich die torte und
dass ich wie alec gemacht violette eben
hier die ganzen musiknoten und die
kopfhörer für geht's halt eben in dieser
serie um musik singend und so weiter
spielt gitarre jetzt wegen die ganzen
komponenten hier braucht und dann habe
ich eine leckere schokolade portal mit
einer show cooking mit schokostückchen
eine heidelberg rehm und waldfrucht
einlage also sehr lecker deswegen zeigen
sich jetzt erst einmal wie man die deko
teile herstellt und dann geht's auch
eine torte bis ich fertig mit den
kopfhörern ich werde es für alle
bauteile egal was jetzt noch mit dem
unternehmen das heißt ja von danzig zehn
prüfer verknetet es gibt aber auch
bereits ein video habe ich jetzt bereit
modelliermasse hinweis auf 5 mm stärke
ausgerollt wird ganz gut mit diesen
hölzern und nehmen jetzt einen heil- und
steckte zwei kreise auch wenn es auch
mal die außenteile vom kopfhörer
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich eine rolle die für 15 cm
im durchmesser und das werden jetzt geht
heile für die augen und zwar scheidet er
jetzt so recht gebe es etwa zusammen mit
essraum kleber und dann nehmt ihr euch
jetzt ein modell exakt zum beispiel
normalen messer oder von schneider
rädchen und könnte sämtliche dem teil
strukturell als nächstes kommt farbe ins
spiel und vornehmlich metallic farben
und werde jetzt im kopf habe mal den
surfer hat mit durchschütteln und dann
mit einem viertel zum beispiel auftragen
das kommt jetzt hier in gewittern und
langer hose ton
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den teilbereich hier
aufgeben
[Musik]
und alle keine die getrocknet werden
müssen legen wir auf dem totenbett ab
erfreulich 1 5 millimeter breites band
und zwar besitzt der bügel vom kopfhörer
darüber den kopf geht
[Musik]
und damit ich später einfach schöne
formen bekommen nämlich dir einen
tortenring ihr könnt aber auch zwei
schnellen runden gegen zu nehmen einen
topf einer schritte und was einfach den
durchmesser hat den ihr gerne möchte
deshalb film findet mit einem
durchmesser und da kann ich doch mal zur
probe außenrum legen
ich habe ich einen kleinen teil violett
eingefärbt mit pasta farbe
[Musik]
spitzenstück violett und weiß kühn
aufgerollt dünner als 3 mm
und jetzt kann ich den violetten teil an
den weiten teil ankleben den kleber
verstreicht ganz schön mit einem pinsel
[Musik]
mit hilfe dieser holzstäbe habe ich das
ganze team fortan gedrückt und vor allem
einfach immer versucht schön gerade
verlassen und verschickt und friedrich 2
keine weiter rechte ecke die dienen
jetzt zur dekoration und da werde ich
jetzt noch zwei kleine schlecker
aussprechen mit hilfe von einer lok
hülle
[Musik]
um dieser runde
für die kupfer habe gibt - zwei ganz
junge violette greife auf gestochen und
zwar etwas dickere weise und beweisen
werde ich erst mal überflutet und
nachteile und trocknen und dann geht's
mit der nächsten übung weiter
[Musik]
violetta ohne die e-gitarre kommen wird
die e gitarre an die reihe
hier habe ich mir einfach vorlag aus dem
internet ausgedruckt und ich hier
bereits ein stück modelliermasse auf 3
mm aufgerollten bisschen antrocknen
lassen damit das papier jetzt hier schön
anklebt hätte ich das mitbekommen kann
man ein bisschen dran kleben und mit
einem scharfen katar auto ein
[Musik]
mit
und für die kleinen teile habe ich die
firma violett ein bisschen dunkler und
heller und setzte einfach noch
ausschweifend auftreten
[Musik]
welches stück weiter modelliermasse 5 mm
dünn ausgerollt und werde die drei
ziffern aufstecken detailliert zwölf
jahre als wird
unter mindestens weder schön in die
porta oben rein stecken kann werde ich
spiele bestätigen
die kläger selbst an
[Musik]
und die tapping ganz als nächstes sind
die klaviertasten dran wie werde ich
gleich in wellen legen und dafür habe
ich jetzt hier weiter modelliermasse
bereit mit der nudel meisten stimmen
ausgerollt vergeht es am einfachsten ist
witzig klett und schneide einfach weiter
fand zurecht gar nicht so lang sein
habe ich meinen styropor termin also von
einer freundlichen sagen und schaue
jetzt einfach mal wie ich mir das später
hinlegt ist schon so viel zu lang so
viel brauche ich gar nicht aber ich
laufe jetzt mal die länge und kann
später immer noch zurechtschneiden und
jetzt zeichne ich mit hilfe eines
lebensmittels farbstifte und des geo
dreiecks einfach diese klaviertastatur 1
[Musik]
nach ein paar takten aufgeschnitten und
zwar sind die harten töne und die werde
ich jetzt mit schwarze mal
natürlich könnt ihr auch einfach auf
schlappe blüten passte ausschneiden und
ausstecken die halben töne die durch mit
ein bisschen durchtrocknen der heilige
steht hier auf ein backblech und stellt
für den backofen ich mache keine
temperaturen aber stellen backofen auf
umluft so kann einfach die luft gestand
ein bisschen durch trocknen und die
klavier noten hier die tastatur darf
jetzt nicht austrocknen will ich mich
sehr gleich noch wegen der elektrolyt
rüber
wir haben loben findet angetrockneten
die werden sich hier draufkleben und
weil ich nicht so das musiktalent bin
habe ich mit 400 fotos ausgedruckt
dadurch sinkt das leben richtig angeht
die musik war grottenschlecht in der
schule dem schulklo im schulchor weil
das man immer nur eins gekriegt nur
mündliche und dann kommt man das so mit
dem raub teil
[Musik]
die temperatur mit pocket was mache ich
hier auf dem styropor tami hat jetzt ein
kleines geschriebene zusätzlich können
auch zum beispiel alufolie oder folie
küchenrolle zu sammeln und das hätte
früher überlegen
[Musik]
und wohl anders seite stehen und habt
ihr noch ein paar noten ausgeschnitten
mit einem cuttermesser und die werde ich
jetzt auch noch gleich schwarz einmal
und alles schön durch die lappen
[Musik]
während die detailliert noch ein
bisschen ausprobieren dürfen kann ich
schon mal die torte füllen hätte die
torte schon mal zwei bilden vorgebacken
und war sehr locker für kuchenteig mein
lieblingsteil und da habe ich ein
bisschen dass kakao zucker mit reinhard
harms und schob dann so richtig
schokolade
hier werde 2000 bilden durchschneiden
einen durchmesser von 24 zentimetern
[Musik]
diese tropft und wenn man später auch
den kuchen weiß oder einen kuchen weiß
dann hat man die so richtig schön
knackig und ich glaube kinder lieben den
ständig kurz zur seite und habe ich hier
bereits meine mutter gehen und vorwürfe
buttercreme gemacht die doppelte menge
und habe vier halbiert die eine hälfte
oder ein bisschen mehr aus die hilfe
werde ich jetzt zu einer heidelberg
trotzdem verarbeiten und die andere für
die habe ich jetzt auch schon
vorbereiteten hat wir wollen einfach in
einem kühlen raum gelagert wie friert
verwendet im kühlschrank könnte auch
lagern allerdings wurde dies wieder noch
mal aufgeschlagen und es geht eben am
besten wenn sie nicht mehr ganz
kühlschrank kalt ist wir haben jetzt
bereits heidel beim fein püriert und
solange ein gekochtes fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr drin der pfeil komplett
mit aussuchen
[Musik]
und die farbe richtig schön wenn man
möchte kann man natürlich auch noch ein
bisschen farbe passe dazu geben dann
passt die farbe nämlich perfekt zum der
torte und butter themen gebe ich jetzt
herren chocolat hatte mit rudi hatten
ganz von schokoladen anteil aber kakao
anteil von 60 prozent
und daher wird bequem dann richtig
lecker schokolade
[Musik]
die torte gefüllt dafür gebe ich von der
heidelberg bequem von einem teil drauf
verstreicht da kommt eine heidelberg
frucht ein merkel braucht eben drauf und
sowie die vordere feld
[Musik]
dort könnt ihr so komplett mit der
butter kleben mit der show geboten
einschränken
allerdings waren sind vorbei doch
einfach hier die ränder schön gerade
sind und nicht beim anschluss später ein
schönes theater spielt habt und die
überreicht heute kann man super naschen
und damit ich die komplett mit der show
oder film einstreichen
[Musik]
ende
so übersehen nämlich ein viel hall vom
land und den habe jetzt bereits gefärbt
in nidda david den aufgerollt und dann
über die torte darüber gelegt
[Musik]
angucken
das geht über zu dem restlichen kader
und dafür nehme ich einfach nur mit
kleber
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich die metallic farben und
auf die andere streich farbe und einen
schwamm und noch eine kleine chance
technik und verrät bot hier unten
einfach von bitten betroffen
[Musik]
ineinander torte vormalig mit den
metallic farben
dafür nehme ich an den pinsel und malta
die männer tief und fest auf
[Musik]
jetzt sind die einzelteile getrocknet
kann ich sehen nehmen
die kuppe zu festigen da bei einem
gestocher gekommen sein
[Musik]
die torten uns zusammengesetzt
mobilität aus ich habe heute übrigens
nur ein klacks für die tour de france
heute lohnen angefangen und heute abend
fertig ich habe allerdings nur den
worten wurden vorgebacken am tag vorher
aber ihr seht man kann auch im gleichen
paket ortes fertig stellen ich finde
aber trotzdem auf zwei tage verteilt
besser dann kann die tochter nämlich gut
durchführen
denn sie ist noch nicht ganz kalt
stellen gleich markant profitiert am
ende aus ganz offen natürlich natürlich
hier am rand den kapitalvorschriften
hoch mit original noten das heißt wenn
jemand instrument spielt könnt ihr gern
nach meinung von anleitungen hier
einfach nur schwer der notenschlüssel
hatte traute gefahren sich vorstellen
den habe ich auf gestochen
aber vielleicht bin ich noch verwendung
dafür jedenfalls kann ich die leute hier
natürlich nicht anschneiden aber ich bin
gleich im anschluss ein paar bilder von
der geburtstagsfeier und auch nicht alle
darüber gefreut hat ich schätze schon
weiter biete nach machen wollt dann geht
auf kelly smith da steht das rezept noch
mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß zum nachbacken und ich hoffe
dass euch kletterfans diese torte
gefällt wenn ja dann lasst mir einfach
einen kommentar
und da freue ich mich natürlich auch
darüber also bis zum nächsten mal und
wer noch einen wunsch hat schreibt gern
unten in die kommentare harry potter
steht natürlich ganz weit oben
und ich möchte auf jeden fall noch
machen
[Musik]
ein
dpa